where the cost of less the king I play
Thierry I'm Ruby I play Lavinia I'm high
side brains for reading I'm sorry
and I've known and we're here to play a
game of who's who know my mind no no no
that is fine I think did you point
yourself I've learned it without change
my change Johnston I think that you know
I actually am gonna stick around to be
picking your is kind of a loser
yeah yeah that's they say he's a bad guy
heist doesn't think he's bad guy I don't
see myself as a bad guy I don't really
see Meridian as a bad guy either so I
might kind of like yeah yeah I know
depends definitely I've done that many
times I'm always late oh how about oh
yeah no not with the coffee but I am
normally I know Islam that would be
Islamic over Islam playing Mormon and he
was always getting coffees
these Islam again yeah I think a mess
never waking up Ruby no you actually
because we always have to get to set
first because we're older and you could
do yes nice I'm sixteen so I could go on
later and cuz of my schooling out of
that yeah so a long as you want it to go
any good huh yeah that one I'm afraid
you can do yourself
I feel like you what is my I like you
would yes I see I've seen abhi oh yeah
you did you kneeled us well thank you
but not in the first thing I'm always
too scared on the first one of these to
them yeah yeah yeah but take take 67
yeah no no it's obviously I would run
you think oh by the way yeah ladies
maybe a minute Joe no no birds no John
is not sure he loved doing things like
making up riddles
yeah you know he'd make up oh my god
wait okay no give me two months to more
minutes two minutes and we'd be thinking
about it for like the whole day I
remember what it was like two steps
forward two sweaters back so annoying
last week what day is it
Amir got it yeah
Oh God okay I can figure out there was
never an on sir speak Nathanial thumb oh
my goodness I know yeah so we only sings
one song
he's mayor's all Bahamian rap see ya
when Bohemian Rhapsody came out we were
we were still filming in a finalist only
Son Bohemian Rhapsody dokely I don't
think you'd ever heard of Queen Ernie
the song is we took him to see the movie
and he just became obsessed and you just
hear him start when I go that's probably
nicer than we do good yeah period how do
you already so organize everything that
involves skill that's know with the
battle plan yeah yeah I made that one I
think of you
just a total you and me was one head
person to fire what I think in whatever
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]